me
bombardements ce matin de tripoli et
bengazi en libye par l'aviation
américaine actions de légitime défense
pour les états unis désapprouvée par une
partie des pays européens la france a
refusé le survol de son territoire par
les bombardiers américains
les libyens ont attaqué des
installations américaines pas de la
sicile colonel kadhafi est vivant et une
demande de cessez le feu libyenne serait
formulée le vice président du conseil
national du patronat français guy
branagh sort indemne d'un attentat
perpétré devant son domicile
les prix la fiscalité le calendrier la
politique économique du nouveau
gouvernement monsieur edouard balladur
ministre d'état ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la privatisation
invités de cette édition
l'écrivain jean genet est mort il était
âgé de 75 ans une carrière de poète
d'homme de théâtre marqué par des
scandales et des rouges est aujourd'hui
mardi 15 avril 1986 les otages français
détenus au liban
marcel carton marcel fontaine michel
seurat jean paul kauffmann et l'équipe
d'antenne 2 philippe rochot georges
hansen aurel cornéa et jean louis
normandin n'ont toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir
quelques heures après les bombardements
de tripoli et de benghazi par l'aviation
américaine provoquant des dizaines de
victimes
les militaires libyens ont répliqué en
attaquant cette après midi l'île de
lampedusa située au sud de la sicile
les installations de télécommunication
utilisés par les forces armées
américaines ont été détruites
cette riposte libyenne était menée alors
que l'on apprenait successivement que le
colonel kadhafi était vivant
en voici les premières images est ce
délibéré
la télévision libyenne ne nous a offert
ce soir que ces quinze secondes des
images du colonel kadhafi
revoyons les attentivement le turban
étonnant pas inhabituel pourtant kadhafi
serait-il blessé à la tête
un regard à l'opérateur kadhafi paraît
très soucieux de son image attitude
détendue jambes croisées mais ce geste
de la main trahit-il soudain une douleur
à la tête le seul à en savoir plus
l'interlocuteur de kadhafi l'ambassadeur
du rss à tripoli kadhafi a changé cet
ambassadeur d'un message pour monsieur
gorbatchev
auparavant le dirigeant libyen avait
téléphoné au président algérien syrien
et sud yéménite ce sont les derniers
éléments de la crise devenue sorte
d'état de guerre entre les états unis et
la libye
il convient d'ajouter que l'ambassadeur
de belgique à tripoli aurait été chargé
par les libyens de transmettre aux
américains une demande de cessez le feu
il faut savoir que la belgique
représente les intérêts américains en
libye
je vous propose maintenant de revoir
trono logiquement ce qui s'est passé
depuis cette nuit à commencer par le
départ des bombardiers américains vers
la libye commentaire de daniel leconte
et philippe gassot
dc à libyenne ne parviendra pas empêché
la tacc l'effet de surprise est totale
les villes de tripoli et benghazi sont
secoués par les explosions en chaîne
le raid durera 20 minutes 300 tonnes de
bombes sont largués pour l'effet de
surprise les américains ont misé sur cet
appareil le peps en or à 23 heures hier
soir 18 de ses bombardiers géométrie
variable stationner sur les bases
américaines quittent l'angleterre
destination la libye ces avions sont de
véritables machines de guerre il vole à
mach 1
plus de mille kilomètres à l'heure aura
des vagues leur précision et diaboli
grâce aux 15 tonnes de bombes à visée
laser embarqué dans leurs plans interdit
de survoler le territoire français les
têtes aux sons ravitaillaient au dessus
de l'atlantique
ils descendent plein sud est après avoir
évité l'espagne s'engouffrent en
méditerranée dans le détroit de
gibraltar au large de la libye au dessus
du golfe de syrte deuxième étape du plan
américain la f111 sont rejoints en plein
ciel par ces appareils de l'us navy de
type intruder ces corsaires catapulté eu
des porte-avions coral sea et america
les bâtiments soviétique habituellement
présents dans les parages ne sont plus
là ils ont disparu depuis trois jours le
premier groupe se dirige sur tripoli
le deuxième sur benghazi à deux heures
du matin heure locale
les premières bombes embrase la libye à
tripoli plusieurs casernes eux sont
bombardés à l'est le cantonnement el
aziz la résidence est le quartier
général du colonel kadhafi est touché
plusieurs personnes appartenant à sa
famille sont blessés au nord c'est
l'aéroport militaire qui est atteint et
à l'ouest les installations portuaires
la seconde vague survolent benghazi elle
anéantit les toutes nouvelles
installations radar couplé aux rampes de
lancement 5,5
selon les américains les objectifs ont
été choisies en raison de leur relation
avec le terrorisme
l' us air force portement quand un
chasseur bombardier f 111 tandis qu'un
appareil endommagé a dû se poser sur la
base américaine de rota en espagne les
chasseurs de l'aéronavale seraient tous
rentrés côté libyen on assure avoir
abattu une vingtaine d'appareils
les images qui nous parviennent de libye
ne décrive aucun objectif militaire
détruits seuls sont privilégiés les
dégâts et les victimes civiles dans les
hôpitaux
les blessés sont des femmes et des
enfants si l'on en croit la ligue arabe
qui soutient le colonel kadhafi le
nombre des victimes dépasserait 70 en
libye on crie vengeance
peu après 4 heures du matin heure
française était un peu plus de 19 heures
aux états unis le président reagan
intervenait à la télévision
nous avons fait ce que nous devions
faire et s'il le faut nous leur ferons a
dit monsieur reggane en justifiant ses
bombardements au nom de la légitime
défense contre le terrorisme monsieur
reagan
un caillou gamme brèches derrière le
président américain pas de fausse note
dans l'opinion publique ni dans le
personnel politique
républicains et démocrates dont edward
kennedy appuyé la décision de monsieur
reggane washington le commentaire de
jacques bouchard devant les journalistes
ce matin larry spx porte parole
présidentiel a révélé que 5836 appels
téléphoniques chiffre record était
parvenu à la maison blanche après
l'intervention télévisée de ronald
reagan 5672 soit 80% des correspondants
soutenait le raid contre la libye
mieux qu'un sondage la présence massive
du public devant les récepteurs à
l'heure du message présidentiel
traduisez l'importance du soutien de
l'opinion
quelques personnes néanmoins
s'interroger sur l'efficacité de
l'action militaire plus rares encore été
ce qui critiquait ouvertement
l'opération autre sujet de satisfaction
pour ronald reagan
la plupart des ténors politiques se
range à ses côtés c'est le cas de
l'ancien secrétaire d'état henrie
kissinger qui égratigne au passage les
européens notamment la france en raison
de leur attitude réticente
presque tous les membres du congrès
tiennent le même langage patriotique
à commencer par edward kennedy pourtant
le leader du sénat robert byrd met les
pieds dans le plat il se demande si le
principal résultat du raid n'incitera
pas les libyens a serré les rangs autour
de kadhafi
il s'interroge aussi sur la suite des
événements et si la syrie et l'iran se
lance dans le terrorisme
que feront les états unis visiblement le
sénateur byrd n'apprécie pas du tout que
l'amérique chausse les bottes du
gendarme
les autorités américaines ont donc
rappelé les attentats que préparait
tripoli soulignant que la france avait
expulsé le 5 avril dernier deux libyens
soupçonnait de préparer une action
terroriste devant le consulat américain
la libye a demandé la réunion du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu pour le chargé
d'affaires libyen à paris c'est une
action de guerre à laquelle il faut
riposter par tous les moyens pour nous
et pour le monde
vrai visage du terrorisme est apparue au
grand jour et le monde est appelé à les
condamner et à les contrer car le peuple
libyen qui est victime de ce
bombardement aveugle a déjà réagi un
abattant trois avions ennemis et
continuera d'assurer sa défense par tous
les moyens
enfin les états unis et c'est qu'ils ont
appuyé apporteront les conséquences de
cette agression barbare la libye et
demandé aux pays arabes de rompre leurs
relations diplomatiques avec washington
et d'appliquer un embargo pétrolier
qu'elle a demandé aux pays membres de
l'organisation des pays exportateurs de
pétrole
noël paix s'est déclaré solidaire de la
libye ainsi que l'algérie l'égypte a
appris avec je cite bouleversements et
grande déception le bombardement
américain et à paris le directeur du
bureau de la ligue arabe craint un
enchaînement d'actions terroristes
je pense que les conséquences les plus
importantes et les plus graves
ce sont les vocations de fanatisme
d'intégrisme de terrorisme que va
susciter cette attaque
je pense qu'il ya là une justification
de la violence qui dans les principales
victimes sont les gens comme nous comme
vous et moi
les modérés ceux qui prêchent la
négociation ce qu'ils prêchent la paix
et qui évidemment sont démenties
catégoriquement violemment le par ce qui
est arrivé ce matin
libre il sera très difficile dorénavant
de dire non au terrorisme convocation
individuelle de violence à moscou le
numéro un soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev
a condamné l'illégalité et l'arbitraire
de l'action américaine constituant selon
lui une détérioration préméditée des
relations soviéto américaine change
bortoli oui l'urss avait deux attitudes
possibles
la première était de condamner
platoniquement le bombardement
on déplore entrée au maire déplorant
sans plus les dommages subis par le
protégé libyen cherche que moscou s'est
contenté de faire jusqu'au début de la
soirée la deuxième attitude est moins
platonique
elle consiste à admettre que l'urss est
directement impliqué dans la sphère
c'est ce que vient de faire monsieur
gorbatchev en déclarant vous l'avez dit
que ce bombardement américain constitue
une détérioration des relations soviéto
américaine
conséquence logique le gouvernement
soviétique annuler la prochaine
rencontre chaude chez varna c'est là
qu'elle devait préparer la rencontre
regan gorbatchev qui de ce fait devient
de moins en moins probable en tout cas
avant l'été
alors pourquoi les dirigeants
soviétiques s'engage-t-il à 600 da soit
réforme il s'engage tout de même en
faveur d'un allié kadhafi qu'il n'adore
pas c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
la réponse est évidente au delà de la
correction administrée la libye il y
avait d'un avertissement à moscou et
moscou se devait de le relever sous
peine de perdre la face les ministres
des affaires étrangères non alignés des
pays non-alignés réunis à new delhi en
inde ont condamné l'attaqué américaine
pour les libyens la grande bretagne est
aussi responsable et pour madame
thatcher
c'est un acte d'autodéfense et c'est
pour cela qu'elle donnait son accord au
décollage des avions américains de leurs
bases britanniques londres
alain cances pour mener à bien leurs
opérations
les américains ont estimé qu'il devait
absolument utiliser les f sentent
capables d'emporter chacun plus de 15
tonnes de bombes
équipé d'un appareillage électronique
hautement sophistiqué ces appareils sont
plus efficaces et garantissent mieux
l'effet de surprise
les bombardiers embarqués sur les
portables les américains devaient donc
partir d'une base terrestre et pour des
raisons politiques
la grande bretagne était le seul choix
possible non seulement madame thatcher a
toujours apporté un soutien fidèle au
président reagan mais encore les
etats-unis ont rappelé avec beaucoup de
vigueur au gouvernement britannique
la dette de reconnaissance contrat qui
est au moment de la guerre des falklands
lorsque les américains n'avaient pas
hésité à aider des anglais cet après
midi aux communes madame thatcher a
défendu l'action américaine
toute la question pour les états unis
était de savoir à quel moment
invoquer le droit de légitime défense au
lieu de rester passif est soumis madame
thatcher a aussi reconnu que la décision
de principe sur l'utilisation des bases
et des prises depuis le week end et qu
elle était confirmée lundi matin il est
donc évident qu hier lors de la réunion
de la zone jefferies à eau
le ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères en savait beaucoup plus qu'il
n'en a dit à ses collègues européens
une attitude jugée pour le moins
équivoque par bien des hommes politiques
britanniques qui redoutent ses
conséquences sur les futures relations
de la grande bretagne avec ses alliés de
l'europe des 12 pour cette raison parmi
d'autres madame thatcher devra faire
face demain à la chambre des communes un
débat difficile
de nombreux parlementaires y compris
conservateurs sont loin très loin d'être
satisfait pas les décisions qu'elle a
prises
la france par les services du ministère
des affaires étrangères fait savoir
qu'elle déplorait cette escalade de la
violence cet enchaînement de la violence
monsieur mitterrand et monsieur chirac
se sont mis d'accord pour refuser le
survol du territoire français par les
appareils américains
ce soir déclarations du premier ministre
monsieur jacques chirac informé des
intentions du gouvernement des états
unis
la france a refusé le survol de son d'un
de son territoire par
les appareils américains elle déplore
que l' escalade intolérable inadmissible
du terrorisme est conduite à une action
de représailles qui relancent elle-même
l'enchaînement de la violence la france
estime que les états européens
au cas où le gouvernement libyen et
mettrait à exécution les menaces qu'il a
proférées à l'égard des pays de l'europe
du sud est explicitement à l'égard de
l'italie et de l'espagne que les
gouvernements européens
je répète devrait décider une riposte
appropriée sur laquelle vous comprendrez
que je ne veuille pas ici et en ce
moment mais tendre mais qui ne pourrait
être que faire
déclaration de monsieur chirac fait
devant les sénateurs la france a demandé
donc cette riposte appropriée
en europe les avis sont assez divergents
notamment entre l'espagne qui condamne
le raid américain et l'allemagne et puis
au parlement européen il ya eu un débat
d'urgence avec interventions notamment
de madame simone veil il faut ajouter en
france la condamnation du raid américain
par le parti communiste et la cgt ce
soir on peut sans doute s'interroger
après la riposte et libyenne sur la
petite île de lampedusa qui n'auraient
pas ce dont notre correspondant victor
vraiment en italie qui n'auraient pas
fait de dégâts aux installations
on peut s'interroger le colonel kadhafi
en restera-t-il à edwards lors où il est
évident ce soir que s'il devait y avoir
une certaine logique dans ce conflit
personne ne se poseraient la question
d'une éventuelle riposte du colonel
kadhafi l'amérique vient de lui prouver
qu'il n'est plus à l'abri d'une riposte
militaire ni lui ni son pays
l'union soviétique brille sur place par
son absence
l'europe ne restera pas les bras croisés
si cada qui s'attaquent à l'italie ou à
l'espagne
sans parler des réactions ou de
l'absence de réaction des pays arabes
alger damas et téhéran viennent de
réaffirmer leur soutien à la libye mais
très diplomatiquement sans plus on est
donc bien obligé de constater mais
seulement de le constater que ce
personnage dérange tout le monde y
compris ses plus proches voisins alors
toute la question est de savoir si la
violente riposte américaine de cette
nuit lui servira de leçon
ou si avec sa redoutable logique à lui
kadhafi va y répondre par le seul moyen
qu'ils contrôlent parfaitement le
terrorisme à new york aux nations unies
la france a décidé de ne pas accepter un
renouvellement du mandat de son
contingent dans la finul au delà de deux
mois au liban au sein de cette force
intérimaire des états unis au liban il
ya actuellement sept cent
quatre-vingt-dix français 16 casques
bleus français ont été tués au sud liban
depuis la création la finul il y a huit
ans la france ne veut plus assurer la
logistique de la force à thème
intérimaire des nations unies au liban
au delà d'une période de deux mois en
france au vésinet près de paris le
vice-président du conseil national du
patronat français guy branagh a échappé
à un attentat ce matin devant son
domicile son chauffeur a été blessé par
deux hommes qui ont mitraillé la voiture
de monsieur branagh cet attentat n'a pas
été revendiqué
en quête d' hervé brusini interrogatoire
du voisinage examens balistiques
le srpj de versailles en pleine enquête
là à terre plus d'une trentaine de
douilles de 9 mm parabellum du 7,62
aussi apparemment les seules traces
laissées par ceux qui ont tenté
d'assassiner guy branagh le vice
président du cnpf opération n'a duré
qu'une poignée de secondes
7h15 ce matin une fourgonnette
s'immobilise devant le numéro 19 de
cette rue du vésinet à ce moment précis
andré ferrandez le chauffeur de libre
anna tous les grilles de la porte
d'entrée la cx de son patron est avancé
deux hommes encagoulés surgissent alors
rafale d'armé automatique
andré ferrand des snacks eu le temps de
se précipiter à terre blessé au visage
et au bras il tente de prévenir gibran à
rester sur le perron de sa maison
mon chauffeur est arrivé tout un second
prix s'étaient jetés
ce record de la voiture et m'a dit sorti
à l'élite est rentré fermer le portail
géré mes distances et aller vite
chercher un fusil ils vont revenir c'est
à vous qu'ils ont elles nous en
parlerons je dois dire que je dois une
fière chandelle à ma femme qui m'a pour
me passer un dernier message et c'est
probablement la seconde qui a fait que
je n'étais pas sous les balles il y a un
an à quelques kilomètres de la résidence
de guy branagh ici à la
celle-saint-cloud l'assassinât du
général audran s'étaient déroulées selon
le même scénario même méthode encore
pour un attentat manqué ici près de la
porte des ternes contre le contrôleur
général des armées
henri blandin deux actions revendiquées
par action directe ce soir c'est la
piste privilégiée par les enquêteurs
mais si guy branagh est un ancien
collaborateur de thomson csf qui
fabrique des armes
cette fois la cible serait le patronat
yvon gattaz et son vice-président ne
l'ont pas oublié le 1er mai 79 le siège
du cnpf été mitraillé un nouveau groupe
terroriste faisait son apparition sans
nom action directe modification des
tarifs publics sncf +3 10% ratp + 8 %
mais baissent pour edf gdf -1% c'était
devant la commission des finances
monsieur edouard balladur bonsoir c'est
vous monsieur le ministre qui avait
annoncé ces modifications de tarifs est
ce que ça ça va pas vous empêcher de
faire un bon score d'inflation ces
modifications de tarifs étaient
nécessaires il faut absolument et c'est
le sens général de notre politique
rétablir la vérité dans les comptes de
l'état veut dire qu'on avait retardé
c'est comme dans le déroulement de
l'économie or il était indispensable que
les prix de les tarifs de la ratp comme
ceux de la sncf pu se relever
rien n'est plus dangereux que d'avoir
des entreprises publiques qui ne font va
payer leurs services à son vrai prix et
qui demande ensuite à l'état d'assurer
la différence c'est la raison pour
laquelle il nous a semblé utile de
procéder sans retard à ces mesures
mais c'est pas une gêne pour combattre
une hausse de l'inflation ce n'est pas
une aide c'est vrai mais notre objectif
demeure une hausse des prix de l'ordre
de 2,4 pour cent cette année
ils raisonnent espoir que nous le
tiendrons ce ministre en matière de
crédit la banque de france vient de
baisser son taux directeur on attend
maintenant de savoir ce que vont faire
les banques
qu'est ce que vous espérez vous en tant
que ministre des finances comme baisse
du prix du crédit
si vous me permettez je voudrais d'abord
revenir sur les motifs qui ont permis
cette baisse du crédit
il ya huit jours nous avons dévaluer le
franc c'est une opération qui a été
décidé dans le secret est dans la
rapidité et grâce à ce secret est à
cette rapidité pour la première fois la
spéculation n'a rien n'a rien gagné au
détriment de la france ça mérite d'être
noté grâce à cette opération
grâce au plan d'accompagnement publié
dimanche dernier et dans lequel la
politique du gouvernement en matière
budgétaire en matière fiscale en matière
sociale a été clairement défini et
annoncée de telle sorte que la confier
la confiance revienne
grâce à cette opération nous avons vu la
semaine dernière rentrée en france
des montants extrêmement élevé de
capitaux de l'ordre le combien je ne
peux pas le dire je peux vous dire
simplement ce que ça dépasse tout ce qui
a été fait auparavant
même en francs constants mais
concrètement c'était de l'argent qui
était parti après le 10 mai 81 n'en sais
rien baudelaire je constate que c'est de
l'argent qui rentre
peu m'importe quand il était parti ou
s'il était parti c'est peut-être aussi
de l'argent qui n'était pas parti de
france qui a toujours été à l'étranger
et qui revient normalement ça vous
choquerait que l'argent s'en aille selon
les changements de régime ont fait
écouter je ne le ferai pas v mon dieu je
constate que la vie est ainsi dans le
monde
alors grâce à cette opération que je
crois réussi nous pouvons commencer deux
à deux actions très importantes
la première c'est remboursé par ati par
anticipation une partie de la dette
extérieure de la france
d'ores et déjà j'ai décidé de rembourser
dans les jours qui viennent par
anticipation une pimpante ans de prêts
de l'ordre de 400 millions de dollars
c'est à dire trois milliards de francs
peu près d'autre part il a été décidé de
ramener les emprunts des entreprises
françaises à l'étranger qui était à 35
milliards de francs devait ramener à 15
milliards de francs et cela aussi grâce
à la réussite de cette opération
donc diminution de l'endettement de la
france
mais ce n'est pas tout il taux d'intérêt
les taux d'intérêts jalousie j'allais y
arriver nous avons eu hier procédé à une
première baisse des taux d'intérêt de 0
50%
baisse qui est encore faible je le
reconnais nous allons dans les semaines
qui viennent
réfléchir et avancer prudemment mais
résolument dans la voie de la baisse des
taux d'intérêt c'est une action qui est
absolument essentielle elle est
essentielle pour lutter contre
l'inflation
elle est essentielle pour permettre aux
particuliers comme aux entreprises
d'emprunter à meilleur prix
elle est donc essentiel pour développer
l'investissement
l'emploi dont vous savez que c'est la
finalité suprême de notre police vous
souhaitez vous souhaitez concrètement
une baisse de combi après cette version
va prendre un détail technique très très
compliqué la voix cette baisse du taux
directeur de la banque de france une
baisse de combien mais je ne peux pas
vous le dire aujourd'hui
l' affaire n'est pas encore totalement
réglé en qu'actuellement absolument
l'argent rentre en france on a parlé
d'une amnistie fiscale qui justement
toucherez ceux qui en avaient mis
ailleurs mais aussi peut-être certains
fraudeurs intérieur est ce que
effectivement une amnistie fiscale est
partie au projet je vous le dirai si
vous le voulez bien demain monsieur
s'assied c'est demain que je présente la
loi de finances rectificative au
gouvernement réuni en conseil des
ministres et que je vais ensuite
l'exposer à la commission des finances
je vous promets de vous répondre mais
vous présenterez également un collectif
qu'on appelle deux collectifs
budgétaires et la loi de programme
certificats c'est plus que vous voulez
rester discret j'aimerais quand même
reconnaître si possible une sorte de
calendrier pour ce qui concerne les
privatisations est ce que vous avez déjà
un certain de deux dates et de déchéance
ça n'est pas dans le collectif
budgétaire c'est dans la loi
d'habilitation laguian sagres et la
question que j'ai défendu cet après midi
que j'ai exposé cet après midi devant la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale et ce matin où ce si les
choses se déroulent conformément à ce
que nous souhaitons
la loi d'habilitation pourrait être voté
d'ici un mois un mois et demi et je
pense que les ordonnances ou l'
ordonnance de privatisation pour vous
pourrez intervenir à la fin du mois de
juin dans le courant du mois de juillet
et c'est ensuite que les décrets
nécessaires seront pris et que les
opérations de privatisation pour ont
commencé quand même car vu les wii en
matière de privatisations la question
vol matière privatisation pour toutes
celles vaut toutes les entreprises
nationalisées d'avant 80
alors est-ce que vous allez suivre les
recommandations dessus mitterrand c'est
à dire est ce que vous allez aller dans
le sens de la cohabitation est ce que
vous risquez d'avoir une rupture et le
président de la république
alcool et nous parlons de cohabitation
si vous voulez bien et à l'heure je
crois qu'il faut pas mélanger les
problèmes la loi est la loi elle
prévoira la liste des entreprises qui
seront privatisés y compris les vieilles
banques rappelle événements y compris
les anciennes banques et les anciennes
compagnies d'assurances ensuite
l'ordonance où les ordonnances devront
mettre les choses en oeuvre et nous
verrons à ce moment là comment les
choses se passent mais vous êtes
déterminés à privatiser
j'aime paris une ville ça me paraît
utile sommes pas et même indispensable
alors vous me parlez de cohabitation à
ce programme
si vous sur les prix ce faisant vous
allez demain donner un calendrier
libération des prix parce que certains
trouvent qu'il ya un petit peu de
lenteur dans la libération des prix
notamment dans les services est ce que
demain vous allez nous donner un cadre
et visons tort ya trois semaines que
nous sommes au gouvernement il semble
que nous avons déjà fait beaucoup de
choses j'ai signé hier je crois la
libération de tous les prisonniers triel
la libération de plus de 50% des prix du
commerce
et c'est déjà un premier pas très
important
le reste viendra en son temps lorsque
leur donnant sur le contrôle des prix ou
plutôt sur la bande à sion du contrôle
des prix et l' ordonnance sur le nouveau
droit de la concurrence que nous voulons
créer sera intervenu dans sur la
cohabitation est ce que vous trouvez que
pour l'instant le ministre des finances
où habite bien avec le sais pas moi le
dire tout ce que je constate c'est que
le gouvernement fonctionne bien que je
crois qu'il agit
efficacement je crois que les pouvoirs
publics sont bien coordonnées je crois
que l'administration travaille bien
qu'elle obéit au gouvernement et jusqu'à
présent je ne peux donc que constater
que la cohabitation se déroule de façon
satisfaisante pour l'ensemble des
français
on vient aux privatisations si vous
permettez la république
alors permettez moi de dire quelque
chose je souhaite que ça continue et je
ferai ce qui est en mon pouvoir pour que
s'accomplisse
mais dans le respect du choix que les
français ont fait en nous confiant la
majorité pour que nous menions une
nouvelle politique une question plus
personnelle pour finir monsieur balladur
vous allaitez secrétaire général de
l'elysée sous le monsieur pompidou est
ce que il ya une grande différence entre
ce que vous avez connu le régime la vie
politique française est ce que vous êtes
en train de biomasse blaine percevait
tout cela il ya pas de différence
fondamentale non à ceci près tout de
même que nous vivons une expérience
nouvelle n'est ce pas et ceci près que
maintenant vous êtes devant les caméras
la quote part avant vous étiez parce que
c'est une différence importante ça lui
faudra que je me chauffe merci monsieur
balladur d'avoir été notre invité
monsieur jacques chirac le premier
ministre et est cet après midi devant le
sénat hommage appuyé au sénat et au rôle
qu'il a joué dans le régime précédent
puis monsieur chirac a rappelé notamment
qu'il proposerait au sénat la loi sur
l'audiovisuel avant de le présenter
devant le parlement la cour d'appel de
riom dans le puy de dôme a confirmé la
décision du tribunal des prud'hommes
concernant alain claveau ouvriers
licenciés de chez dunlop pour avoir
commenté ces conditions de travail dans
le quotidien l'humanité
la cour d'appel s'est déclarée
incompétente alain claveau devra saisir
de nouveau les prud'hommes s'il veut
être réintégrés aux assises de paris
l'avocat général a requis la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité contre lionel
cardon accusé du meurtre d'un policier
au mois de novembre 1983
le verdict pourrait être rendu demain
soir il fut provocateur et scandaleux
déserteurs et homosexuel il fut le plus
inclassables des écrivains de l'après
guerre a dit le ministre de la culture
françois léotard avec lui disparaît un
soleil noir qui nous éclaire l envers
des choses explique jack lang jean genet
est mort
à l'âge de 75 ans il était poète
romancier homme de théâtre et de cinéma
commentaires daniels part
ils étaient amis simone de beauvoir et
jean genet se sont éteints quelques
heures d'intervalle jean genet toute une
vie sous le signe de la provocation la
violence la révolte les années sens
prise en charge par l'assistance
publique il est confié à des paysans du
morvan son adolescence il la passe dans
une maison de correction il s'évade
s'engage dans la légion cuisine déserte
et se mettent à vagabonder voleurs
déserteurs homosexuels voyous et bientôt
taulard mais du fond de sa cellule à
fresnes il écrit le condamné à mort le
voyou est devenu écrivain
je suis très vite
s'ils s'engagent à peu près
que je ne pourrais que vagabond ou
valeur un voleur je crois que je me fais
un prêt d'y avoir une émotion telle
qu'elles ne pourraient être qu'elles le
pourraient même mener que faire les
creepers
jean genet écrit des poèmes des romans
notre dame des fleurs le miracle de la
rose des pièces de théâtre les bonnes le
balcon jouer ici à sao paulo un style
flamboyant mais surtout un cri comme une
arme pour venger les humilier les expos
en 1961 représentation départ avant la
guerre d'algérie de par genêt l'extrême
droite se déchaîne genre jeu mais
n'écrit plus pays ne s'étaient pas et
s'engage aux côtés des black panthers
lui défend la cause palestinienne
il y a trois ans danièle delorme avait
filmé ses confidences
et quand je vais demander de faire un
petit texte pour présenter ce film pour
dire pourquoi ils l'avaient fait alors
que jusque là il n'avait jamais accepté
de s'exprimer
il m'a dit je vais vous faire un petit
texte et le texte celui-ci son acte de
naissance porte ceux ci né le 19
décembre 1910 à 10 heures du matin de
gabriel genêts et de père inconnu sauf
ces livres on ne sait rien de lui non
plus que la date de sa mort qu'il
suppose prochaine
sport football après le transfert de
fernandez aux racines on appris
aujourd'hui le départ de josé touré le
nantais pour bordeaux celui que l'on
appelle le brésilien qui est
actuellement blessé dira pas à la coupe
du monde le mexique et un match c'était
face au paris saint germain en coupe de
france et la manière dont pourrait y
avait marqué le 2e but c'est pour cela
qu'on l'appelait le brésilien josé touré
tu vois donc avec les girondins de
bordeaux la saison prochaine ou qui ont
appelé également le transfert de
l'international allemand pierre
littbarski au racing de paris pour la
météo on vous retrouve l'agencé table
oui eh bien ça vient rossavia un très
doucement j'ose à peine vous dire que le
printemps s'installe et pourtant
regardez la photo satellite avait
toujours une dépression sur l'irlande
et puis ces perturbations qui sont déjà
passés sur la france à leur donnant on
va se retrouver en ciel de traîne qui
dit ciel de traîne dit un peu moins
d'averses et un petit peu plus
d'éclaircies c'est ce qu'on aime c'est
ce qu'on retrouve sur la carte du temps
prévu avec nous allons voir dans
quelques instants la carte du temps
prévu toujours des nuages et un temps
couvert sur l'extrême est du pays des
précipitations le matin sur le sud des
alpes et sur le sud du massif central
mais ces nuages vont s'éloigner vers
l'est dans la journée temps relativement
agréable avec encore quelques nuages
résiduels
évidemment on peut pas ils peuvent pas
partir tous d'un seul coup et puis de
nouveau des nuages un petit peu plus
nombreux le soir sur la bretagne et sur
la norme anti côté température et bien
elles s'harmonisent de 10° à cherbourg
et à bray jusqu'à 16 degrés à biarritz à
toulouse et à ajaccio température qui
s'harmonisent sur toute l'europe
puisqu'elle fera demain 11 degrés et à
venise et à londres
notre agenda pour terminer demain sera
le mercredi 16 avril le soleil se lèvera
à 7h se couchera à 20h44 de soleil en
plus et nous fêterons les benoît-joseph
le dernier journal de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 où sera présenté à minuit
par philippe harrouard à demain 20h
bonsoir merci
e